de maison en maison il doit courtisé
tous les électeurs le jour du scrutin le
moindre vote compte pour le candidat
libéral sortant ken macdonald
élu pour la première fois en 2015 même
si les libéraux prennent sur la
circonscription depuis onze ans cette
fois la division du vote pourrait
brouiller les cartes
les résidents d'ici sont aux premières
loges des changements climatiques et il
dit sont de plus en plus sensibles mais
ici beaucoup gagnent aussi leur vie
grâce à l'industrie pétrolière difficile
de plaire à tout le monde
lui travaille dans les sables bitumineux
il pourra croire en justin trudeau
lorsque le projet de pipeline trans
manten ira de l'avant
de l'autre côté de la rue cette jeune
maman souhaite plutôt que l'on s'attaque
sérieusement au changement climatique
les verts ont bien saisi cette
sensibilité à l'environnement ici et en
profite pour présenter un candidat très
connu j'habite terre-neuve-et-labrador
je n'ai pas besoin d'en dire plus dit
cette dame c'est que le policier est
aussi acteur il s'est fait connaître
dans la série télévisée humoristique
code qu à siby si si à l'époque il
prenait les questions d'environnement à
la légère
aujourd'hui il les prend très au sérieux
il est convaincu que ses concitoyens
sont prêts pour du réel changement nous
avons atteint un point de non-retour
dans cette dame cet homme nouvellement
grand père considère aussi faire sa part
pour l'avenir de ses petits enfants
est-ce que sa notoriété il sa cause lui
permettront de gagner
difficile à dire c'est matthew chapman
qui représente les conservateurs un
enseignant qui lui contrairement aux
deux autres doit mettre les bouchées
doubles pour se faire connaître son plan
s'attaquer au coût de la vie élevé de la
province la plus endettée par habitant
au pays et abolir la taxe carbone bon
limites sur la participation des
personnes âgées pour se faire élire et
sur les travailleurs de l'industrie du
pétrole
le nouveau parti démocratique lui
presque invisible la mainmise rouge donc
pour épier perdre de son éclat fera 5
pouces et des verts et à une bonne
campagne des bleus ici et les à céret
radio-canada paradise